[Music]
hakam's is a program that DARPA ran for
four and a half years that was focused
on using techniques from what are called
the formal methods communities so
techniques based on math more or less to
produce software for vehicles that came
with proofs that the software had
certain desirable properties that it
parts of it were functionally correct
that there were no bugs and certain
kinds of certain kinds of bugs in the
software and the consequence of those
proofs is that the system is much harder
to hack into so the formal methods
community has been promising for like 50
years that they could produce software
that provably didn't have certain kinds
of vulnerabilities and for more or less
50 years they have failed to deliver on
that progress that promise yes they
could produce proofs of correctness for
code but for you know ten lines of code
or 100 lines of code not enough code to
make a difference for any kind of
practical purpose but recently there's
been advances in a bunch of different
research areas that have changed that
equation and so now formal methods
researchers can prove important
properties about code bases that are ten
thousand or hundred thousand lines of
code and that's still small potatoes
compared to the size of Microsoft
Windows or the size of Linux which are
millions hundreds of millions of lines
of code but what when you start to get
to ten thousand a hundred thousand lines
of code there are really interesting
software artifacts that fit in that size
things like compilers and micro kernels
and you can leverage those kind of
exquisite artifacts to build much more
complex software systems where only a
small part of the system has to be
verified to be functionally correct and
then you can have lots of software
running sort of on top of it that isn't
software correct that doesn't have that
same level of assurance associated with
it but that you can prove it doesn't
matter what it does it's not going to
affect the operation of the overall
system
so for example hakam's researchers used
the high assurance code and put it on a
Boeing unmanned little bird which is a
helicopter that can fly completely
autonomously or can fly with two pilots
and this helicopter has two computers on
it one is the mission control computer
that controls things like fly over there
and take a picture fly over there and
take a picture and communicate to the
ground station the operator who's
telling the helicopter what to do it
also has a flight control computer that
controls things like altitude hold and
stability
sort of the mechanics of flying the
helicopter in any given time at any
given time period so the researchers put
SEO for microkernel which is a verified
Mongo kernel guaranteed to be
functionally correct on the mission
control computer and they used it to
create different software partitions so
one of those partitions was responsible
for communicating with the ground
station another one of those partitions
was responsible for operating the camera
that the the helicopter had the
researchers verified that the code in
the communicate with the ground station
was functionally correct and isolated
from the software in the control the
camera part so the camera part was all
the legacy software that had previously
been on the helicopter to control camera
operations they allowed the red team to
additionally put the red team is a group
of people who are charged with trying to
take over control of the helicopter
against the wishes of the legitimate
operator so they're trying to hack in
take over control disrupt the operation
of the helicopter so in this setting the
red team was allowed to have root access
so unfettered access within the camera
partition and charged with break out of
this take over control the rest of the
helicopter disrupt the operation of the
helicopter in any way corrupt the
messages to the ground station basically
interfere in any way you can with the
legitimate operation of this helicopter
the red team had no full access to the
source code they understood all the
design documents they knew as much about
the system as you could reasonably
expect to know and after six weeks they
were not able to break out they were not
able to disrupt the operation of the
copter at all all they could do was they
can fork bomb themselves they could
basically crash their own process but
the rest of the helicopter would then
notice that that process was crashed and
restarted again restoring the operation
of that the camera so that's an example
of where you could use the formal
methods based techniques to create this
kind of thin level at the bottom which
was the SEO for microkernel and then
leverage that to produce sort of the
full functionality of the helicopter and
they you know the camera functionality
might come and go as hackers break in or
don't break in but you're guaranteed
that the helicopter will be still able
to communicate to the ground station and
fly appropriately
[Music]